- But wait have any of your
Office people have they
come to see you?
- Yes, Angela came the first week.
Oscar came, Andy Buckley
who played David Wallace.
Creed Bratton, who plays Creed Bratton
and Leslie David Baker, who plays Stanley.
- Oh my god that's so supportive.
(audience applauds)
I love that.
- I know and I've gotten so such support,
even online from Jenna, Steve
Carell did a video for me.
I mean--
- He's the nicest.
- He's the greatest.
- He did something very lovely--
- Of course he did when
they pulled his hair out,
he yelled Kelly Clarkson.
- I was always kind of
like, was it a compliment?
I don't know.
You're in pain and you think of me.
I ran into him and I asked his wife,
I was like, you give the
truth and she did. (laughs)
It was nice.
I do hear that there might
be a reboot of The Office,
is that real because can I
sign a petition of something.
- I am not the one getting in
the way if that his happening.
I would love to.
Seriously it was the best
nine years of my life, ever.
- How many great actors.
- And the fact that it still
lives oh my gosh.
People are living and
breathing The Office right now.
Like literally they will come up to you
and say, "I fall asleep
to you every night."
Now a few years ago
that might creep me out
but I like it now.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
You know what I mean
because literally they say,
I watch it all, it's like a white noise
I leave it on all day, all day.
I'm like, wait a minute,
that means you're not paying attention
but it's like in their bones.
- But it's that entertaining.
It's good, it's great writing great cast.